a lot of people look at the die and
they're like well if you had just
removed processed foods you'd be fine
and I did do that I did that first
because that's more obvious I removed
everything I thought I could be allergic
to nuts eggs dairy all processed foods
grains and went down to like meat and
greens and fruit I did that to begin
with and then I stopped taking
antidepressants and I went off of all my
medications and I got pregnant and that
stopped working so then I went to meet
and lettuce I was just eating meat and
lettuce and apple cider vinegar and
olive oil not olive oil cut with soybean
oil just pure olive oil and that was
giving me an autoimmune disorder it
wasn't until I dropped the literally
lettuce apple cider vinegar olive oil
and went to the lion diet that my
arthritis went away and my mood improved
so it's not from cutting processed foods
it's more than that